welcome few things
who here was at my talk earlier on today
who was at my talk earlier on today okay
who wasn't at my talk earlier on today
how about that okay yeah he wasn't okay
cool I will repeat for you through a few
things pretty fast so so kind of what
we're going to cover today is two things
really so we're going to cover two
examples we're going to work through
with ten so jess what I'm going to use
that mobile net model which I kind of
talked to talked about today in in the
talk and the other one we're going to do
regression so an example something
called linear and polynomial regression
and I thought I think we've only got
time for today because if we've only got
three hours we've only got a little bit
of time today there's normally if you
want to do the full one oh this is like
an eight hour plus workshops ain't got
time for two and what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna have if I can have you all
join how would actually check these
links I just created them do they work
they don't work
that's all an elaborate hoax to get you
to buy more Microsoft if I don't know
why is I not working so I made it a
slack a slack so you could is that Rena
working damn how is that not working let
me go here
Wow
do I have to click something what I call
it t FJ s T oh I know why let me check
that
boom so I hope it would someone try it
out it should be TF j s WS / slack and
that's what I'm going to post kind of
bits of code and links and things I've
had to make it easier for you as you go
through there should be a room called J
s Kampf Asia
- TF j s check out there's actually the
my especially my the the slack for our
meetup group in in London so I recommend
after the workshop unless you're from
London leave this like because we
channel announce stuff all the time
new new would you call them meetups yep
yeah so I arrived last night and I I
didn't mind she have to sleep all night
so I'm not too sure what's going to
happen today we'll see I mean the other
thing Oh same here should be tfj s WS /
mobile net so basically don't clone that
visit that URL and I'll take it to the
github and clone that github - to begin
with I'll give you I'll give you a few
minutes for that yeah yeah as people -
just log on to the slack I have not
checked the link at all
has anyone successfully logged in to
slack yeah okay excellent I can't check
it because uh I'm on the thingy and
go try a new second screen see see if
that works
I swear
oops
start to whistle it's probably not a
good sign
so I get up yeah it should be tfj s WS
yeah w yes
ah sorry one second
where's my mouse on mouse as well
and one of the things duets just let me
just two seconds while I set this up
yes
yes oh my god it worked the first time
ever it actually worked first time yes
yes yes yes oh my god this is so
exciting hungry this is working
[Music]
you just arrived could quickly take us a
snapshot of that screen because it's
going to go in a second
I'm okay actually yeah I got also it
actually I should why am I facing this
way it's the wrong way to face on the
face the other way yeah sorry the sec
I'll just fix it I keep on saying yeah
I'll just fix it hang on
oops
the second one is WS both of my WS yeah
both from a WS tfj SWS yeah mom's day
it's gonna be situate myself there we go
things are gonna get a little bit iffy
I'll come out this way this is the way
I'm going to come out sorry
yeah facing out probably the best way so
I'll turn it round oh man this is just
spectacular I'm doing here isn't it I'm
gonna unplug and plug in it
all right
what's behind me that thing
okay now you have to wait again
oh that man
was I going
yes okay
where was I
all right here we go I'm just gonna go
it's gonna go alright so hopefully
buddy's got that if you weren't a my
talk this morning
I'm trying to very very quickly go
through some of the things I went
through again this one if you're at Mike
if you were my talk this morning
considerate revision so I run a co one a
meetup group coffee I drove one then
this is where you can find out
information about me especially my
Twitter you can follow me on Twitter do
you want to do that follow me oh come on
take a pictures let's do a picture after
layer the agenda today so this is all
what we're going to cover is a really
brief over you've neural networks and
ten so jess if you're a my talk this
morning then that's gonna be old news
I'm going to go through mobile net the
thing I gained I showed you this morning
going to very quickly go over actually
to start dipping your toe into some some
of this stuff and then I'm I'm really
sorry about this there's just no way
around it this is like this is the
gentlest I can do it does the gentlest I
can do it but it's going to be a steep
ramp up from mobile net to regression
but this is the simplest use case that
there is so I apologize not don't
apologize you need this is just your
life if you want to do machine learning
right just your life we're never gonna
go through can what's called regression
linear regression and poornam polynomial
regression hopefully quite a lot of this
you're gonna be sitting there on your
computers tapping away working trying to
fight yourself I'm I'm here if you've
got any questions I try and help out as
much as I can
turn to the person next to you do you
write to twist your right to your right
see hi welcome that doesn't make any
sense does it doesn't work at all
say hello and introduce yourself to the
person to your left and to your right
all right okay say hi and assume I
Christine that's me yeah yeah
[Music]
good help each other out there's a lot
of people in this room and it's going to
be very difficult for me to kind of
cover up and ask and answer questions
from everybody if you solve something
the person next to you is struggling you
know help them out helped type on slack
you know if you see it sees somebody
asking questions you know type loss that
help each other out as much as possible
because it's nice to do that yep
so introduction so what we're gonna be
doing there's a very different different
types of machine learning we're gonna be
doing well
yeah supervised machine learning today's
but some essential what you do is you
get some training data in this type of
model you get some training date and I
usually is something that a human being
has labeled in some way as in a human
being has looked to that and said I
think this is this or I think this is
this okay and so training data and you
kind of define that out algorithm and
then you train it and that what the
water generates is a model there's lots
of different types of classifiers many
many different types of them what we're
going to do today is using a neural
network method and the outputs are model
right and let's say this is a model
which you trained it up using sentiment
analysis with some words so new a
sentence is a positive sentence or a
negative sentence and then when you give
it something it's never seen before like
I love Assam it can say that's positive
so that's kind of what what this stuff
is really good for is you train up on
one set of data then you can give us
something it's never seen before and it
can come to a conclusion as to what that
is that's kind of opposite to what we'd
normally do if we're programming you
have to kind of always think of every
single edge case and it'll only ever
give you an answer based off of what
your program that's kind of the
underlying fundamental power of machine
learning is okay can can
infer and give you answers to stuff that
you've never even it's never even seen
before
so we're using tensor flow it is
currently I still think the most popular
open source package for machine learning
this is an old slide but at the time the
next big biggest thing was like it alone
just thirty thousand but since those 100
thousand it's probably been surpassed
that a lot as I said this morning we use
intensive ajs test by Jess comes with
two different api's inside the two
different kind of yeah api's I usually
use something call the core API which if
you using tensorflow
like Python and other versions of it
that's what you see is a core API it's
very low level you if you looked at
something like that you'd have to really
squint to see the neural network it's
kind of like looking at a program and
trying to figure out exactly or it then
it's like that the building parts of a
program so if you're really just doing
neural networks all the time there's
also abstractions that you can use and
for that there's there's something
called carers if you doing in Python you
use chaos which gives you a high level
of perspective all you're doing is in
your network but what 10 to 5 J and that
that in normally that's a separate sort
of package but intensified J's have
combined it so that you two API isn't
one the core API and the layers API
however today you're not looking at the
layers API because we don't have time
for that you're going only for the core
API brisk up tonight right
what I'm going to show you in the core
API is going to be like this mean lines
of code and if you use a layers API it
would be like two lines of code or
something but I think it's good to
understand how things work underneath
because otherwise you don't know you're
just using some line of code your
networks
pretty boring the rest of you because
this is exactly the same slides as it
today anyway bases on a base based on
biology so it's a neuron you have
dendrites going in a body and axons
going out if enough electricity flows in
the dendrites the body goes and push you
so much just via the axons that's what
we do here but we're doing exactly the
same thing just in code you have a node
the electricity going in is your data
one sample of your data that you're
pushing in so whatever that is I'm going
to go through it but whatever that is
then you have these edges and for each
of those dendrites going in you have to
know how important that piece of input
is to the to the end result that we have
something called a weight initially it's
just randomized to random number
you just push them through an activation
function and you output one whatever the
output activation function outputs you
then type that into the next one's the
next one to the next one there's loads
of different activation functions which
this is one of them very simple anything
below zero is zero anything above zero
is one as I'm speaking to you I realize
that throughout what you're going to
cover today we're not going to touch on
an activation function but it's good to
know because we're not going to use
because normally when we using the
layers API we start touching on the
activation function and stuff like that
right now it's good to know so this is
one of them
it's good because it's really easy to
calculate and I mean through the machine
learning you want stuff that's easy to
calculate so it doesn't require too much
processing power and compute but it's
really bad because
changes in tiny changes the input is a
huge change in the output so there's
other ones that people use this is a
hyperbolic tanh it kind of gives you a
little bit more no non-linearity um but
this is a very common one people use
call rail you and if you actually
covered off more the recipe I can point
you out to the there's there's two
further examples you can do if you go
home when you go home if you go when you
go home and they'll they'll show you
example no double using value but this
is it's a good one okay it's kind of
it's a nice compromise because it kind
of easy to calculate and does give you
some non-linearity so it's kind of nice
you kind of pump it all together you get
a geek rate loads of those you join them
together you're not going to do that
today you complicate it you're gonna do
one neuron and you'd be like God
wouldn't you want so hard you doing one
neuron today but if you did be wanted
you can connect a whole bunch of them
together like this and if if here's the
core API you would literally be creating
a neuron and urine and urine in your
between the layers API you just say a
layer with three a layer with two a
layer 3 and it kind of figures the rest
out for you but that's what you're
basically doing then you feed it some
input data whatever that is what are you
trying to Train on depends on what that
is it just multiplies everything out and
gives you a number so I can't remember
what what did I say this is this is my
example with the faces today
but what I say this when I've got the
the faces in this in this slide I don't
know but anyway this was supposed to be
an example of facial features you pump
it in
it gives that a number let's say we know
this input data or should be have been
eight instead of instead of three we
know it's wrong by five of course it's
gonna be wrong because we would have
initialized around the things randomly
and then what you do is you do this
thing called back propagation or tuning
or it's actually optimization right
you're trying to change these numbers so
the next time you pass this thing all
this data through it's gonna give you a
eight and that's what the training which
what training a neural network was
training this stuff that's what we're
doing we're just tuning these numbers
using a loop and tend to flow so that
the next time it goes through it's just
going to give us a name I'm gonna tune
those numbers to some value right that's
kind of tensorflow J s then stencil flow
that's kind of really high-level
overview of a neural network and yeah
that's right so what's go through but
what we're gonna do for the very very
first example so what so once you once
you trained up one of those networks you
can actually save them I'll show you
ah
wait what can you see right now no
nothing you
I want to mirror this screen that's what
I want to do sound dude that's what I
want to do yeah
yes this is what I wanna do okay so if
you go to
[Music]
you go it's just business if you go here
there's tens of flojet tensorflow
org oh it's changed since vote.org / j r
/ models this is where you can find a
whole bunch of the kind of pre free made
models that are available that is
growing it's growing so the one we're
gonna use is mobile map we see you can
see there's a bunch of others toxicity
is a new one so toxicity and if you've
got demo of it well done
then what toxicity does is it it doesn't
just tell you if a piece of text is bad
or good it tells you if it's offensive
and and in what way is it offensive so
it tells you where dude on confuse [ __ ]
you are quite astonishingly stupid it's
not an identity attack it is an insult
it's nob scene so you can see you can
have life stuff is happen and identity
attack on to what somebody it's kind of
an interesting an interesting use case
this one does this I think this is the
latest one they've got it's growing
you can try finding some yourself these
are the ones that kind of very well
nicely packaged and it's just a really
great way if you just want to get
started another put your jobs with
developers here so we kind of just like
MPM installing stuff and then just
getting on with it just a good way of
playing around with it another really
fun one the two really fun ones here
actually posing that is a very fun one I
wonder if I can start the demo myself
try the demo here here we go
but you know what I'm gonna be rude when
I want to get somebody to like volunteer
there we go I need a volunteer probably
probably used to go and stand up yeah go
and stand up so you can see and move
about that's pretty cool right
yeah yeah courageous I've just haven't
at the time I wanted to make like a
flossing game see if you can count do
the flossing because you can actually
multiple people so I often thought you
could have two people I'm making a
flossing game make it one of you make it
right and another really fun one but
I've only really started to play with is
speech so you can actually can actually
recognize speech online demo done I've
got an online demo it does have an
online demo car number is essentially
they've got a model here which is which
which has been trained up to recognize
the numbers 0 to 9 up down
stop yes no and it can just recognize
those words just using the browser on
the Web Audio API so that's pretty cool
so it's at the bottom ah there you go
I was gonna download isn't it anyway
that's how it works with we're going to
use the artists who yeah down eight yes
oh yeah
yeah that's pretty cool but we're gonna
using the mobile on that one today to
play around with so there's my slides
from another on there
I think this is it actually no no that's
not gonna work
yeah yeah that's how it so hopefully
should all get cloned this thing by now
want your computers so we'll learn how
to load and use a pre train model and oh
where to find preacher moles gone the
wrong way around it's okay it's not the
end of the world and yeah so basically
underneath all a lot of this stuff is
going to be tf2 load model which is
going to load those models underneath
and
[Music]
yeah and this is mobile map let me use
it in this way we're gonna use it in a
slightly different way but because I'm
not gonna use import statements we're
gonna do via script tags as all websites
should be made script tags all right
give me two seconds while I get set up
because I need to get my head straight
so let me get my this is not it
oh yeah how about that excellent
Oh
Oh
oh why why do I have C++ extensions
so I think I'm gonna revert this okay
if you want and it's gonna be pretty
simple for a lot of a lot of you but
trust me you're gonna remember this
moment later on and you've got me like I
wish we were doing mobile mobile on that
again because it's going to get it's
gonna get steep gets deep pretty fast
dipping your toes in so you should see
can you see this now probably not
[Music]
oh dang it's not supposed to do this
so what this is what I'm going to do I
want to load up the completed one so if
it that in the folders you see main main
dock completed in main dock Jas maybe
some of you've already cheated you've
looked at the dock completed code yeah
well this is basically what you'll end
up doing or should and should end up
looking like oh wow that's awesome
that's brilliant
how's that
this is good can someone take a video of
this
cool um let me just refresh that because
that the canvas been all wrong there and
then why is that not so yeah I think
because I'm screen showing the canvas is
a bit wrong anyway
so um this is gonna not not gonna work
because my screens it's just not doing
that anyway whatever so the bottom of
the screen it's detecting what's in the
image this is crazy what if like ah
barbershop monitor no it's not just kind
of phone maybe phone great
modem I don't think because it confused
because things behind it iPod iPod at
the bottom iPod close enough close
enough so that's why it basically what
it's what it's doing this was I was been
wearing earlier on today and it's how
we're gonna what we're all going to
build today so all that we've done here
is to is two things
oops this is hmm there's an old version
- I haven't baited it I'm not gonna bait
it don't date it keep it as it is so
what I'm doing is I'm loading up tents
Flo Jess
at the top is 11.0 now I haven't updated
in a while so but it's the same for this
demo it'll be exactly the same and the
other thing I'm doing is loading up
mobile net at the top there as well so
you could if you're doing this properly
so derisive on I properly do like import
statements in a bundle or something like
that but I'm just genius script tag and
I've got my career's going main dot
jeaious test for jess is its thing let's
go take a look at what mobile net looks
like haha on the internet and our notes
here how'd you open you didn't know did
I open it no didn't yeah yeah
so all that mobile and that is when
you're when you're downloading is it's
just it's just if I go into source here
index
all the mobile that's doing is if you
look really closely at the source code
whereas it going
I have to be doing it different we're
doing it ah okay there's another way of
bloating agent use blood graph model
it's all this doing underneath this is
just a nice wrapper around tensorflow
just to help you it's football mobile
man but all it's doing underneath is
using load graph model and passing in a
JSON file which is kind of depending on
the version number it's whatever this is
Jason or something along those lines but
when done loading in this mobile and
that thing all it's doing is just doing
some nice bits of code so you don't have
to do all this stuff yourself but it's
just loading up a JSON file with TF the
load graph model and the other kind of
really interesting file and also what
it's doing is when you ask classify
classify that's the code that you're
going to use you're gonna pass it
something usually like an image we can
pass a canvas a video image date or just
like some raw numbers and then what it
does is calls infer right when you load
up a model you you give it some once you
train that you call infer you give it
some new data and it gives you the
response back but all it's just giving
you what we're all numbers like really
really raw numbers it's not really
giving you something you but you need to
understand what what's actually going on
and so it just has some nice helper
classes helper functions to kind of turn
those raw numbers into something
meaningful ie a string that describes in
the image and so it's caused the thing
called top K classes
which which which basically loads up
this file and this is the interesting
file here imagenet class is because the
end of they were all the models are
changes a number what does that number
mean well this is going to tell you what
that number means so this is these are
all the thousand things that mobile net
can understand is it toilet tissue
toilet paper a bullet we all know what
ball that is I've got several bullets
agaric I don't know what this is this a
gyro mitra stink horn anyway scuba diver
wow that's all that mobile net can read
detect and these are the things that
mobile net knows how to detect right
which is why it's not so good but it's
small enough so it can actually be
usable on a mobile all right so that's
basically what's doing let me just get
up
visually occurred inside us
in fact what they ever need to do that
here and just do this
no closure yeah I'm just gonna do this
way
okay
[Music]
yes
all right so oh okay the icons changed
cool
yeah does that happen a while ago
there's a few days ago man I've been on
a plane forever don't know this stuff
anymore alright so you should see you
should see something like this and your
main the main file first thing you
should do is like obviously there's
hints there to do one what do we need to
do we need to load the mobile on there
to start the camera so all you need to
do is do is load the model yeah mobile
net is already in your namespace put you
loaded up with a script tag we didn't do
anything
wow it's gonna be very difficult for you
isn't it Oh No
maybe we can turn that screen that way
and you can you all see this screen from
that side yeah so we can send that one
for the piece behind try it go on
[Music]
Oh opportunity for myself that picture
picture
okay that's the wrong way around
every way yeah on this side this is it
wait wait hang on yeah yeah cool awesome
Oh got some professional ones as well
don't worry I got it
cool ok you get you'll get excellent and
what that's doing underneath as I showed
you before this is just going and it's
caught that that mobile net is just
getting the finding the right Jason for
whatever version number we're running I
mean it's just calling the load graph
model underneath it's literally going to
go across the network and just download
quite a lot it's actually quite a large
model still a Congress eyes of it is but
it's there's multi megabytes downloading
onto computer right even mobile net it's
quite large right you wouldn't just like
have it on your homepage for your for
you don't do that because it's pretty
big then
okay then they pretty simple we need to
pass the canvas so where am I
I'm lost classify image
classify me okay so then
oh I can't explain what the codes doing
I'm sorry so it's just doing kind of
basically pretty simple pretty simple
stuff it's getting it's using the kind
of getusermedia API which is going to
get a stream from the camera okay and
then what we do every second I call take
snapshot so every have a sent or let me
second on the call take snapshot are all
about doing all that that's doing is
from the video stream it's grabbing one
frame and that's a drawing
it's that drawing that frame interest in
it into a context yeah and then it's
called let me call in classify image
right so then we have the image than
what we asked you now we want to know
every second we want to after we've
loaded the model in term we want to know
what's inside it so it's pretty simple
really just do predictions
okay predictions they gotta wait model
dot classify that's it that's it right
I know you're all going to stay simple
assume it's real easy
yes is easy I'm gonna remember this
moment
you're gonna dream about this moment you
know wish this man was going to come
back to you all right this is it all
right and I can't spell predict yeah
okay I don't even know why but to do the
next one you can do what you want
basically that that just returns for you
like if you if you want to print that I
could print it on the console and see
what actually returns I think it returns
an array yes it returns an array and
then I'm just going to print that
somewhere on the on the page so if you
if you're like a proper developer and
not proper that's horrible thing to say
you're if you use one of the web
frameworks in the world you probably
there's a better way of doing this but
if you're a vanilla person like me
there's that works I'm of another person
I'll paste this in there just just just
just for the sake of saving everybody a
headache and want to paste this into the
slack Channel yeah just so you can cut
you can just copy and paste that there
guess what that's it
done you've loaded a model and you've
used it so now if I I'm still my stall
looking at main but yes I am there
OOP whoa look at now you can't see if I
look at this way
laughs okay back in the pirate party
parrot
if you're asking power hang on my scream
I can't hang on why don't I just record
the desktop
there we go
this is just ignore me for a second
okay
very good
from awesome and that's it so you should
all be seeing this working well that's
no I forgot that that isn't the point
the point is this so hopefully on your
computer people - get working yeah
powerful interesting it is crazy
it's absolutely crazy that we can do
this so we live in this world full of
surprises and technological miracles on
a daily basis but just let's take a
second just appreciate what's happening
right now in a browser is detecting what
it's seeing
epic
it's the only word that you could use to
describe knives maybe with some other
words
that's it I'll give you a moment whoa
design prison let's come up with some
weird ones
oh it just said it just said I was a
microphone because my bed yeah
and again I'm going to leave it give you
a few seconds while I plug in and was an
hour already
no you serious no it was 45 minutes
huh toilet seat I didn't say it was any
good right just that it does stuff all
right little bit can it can it sector
this thing what's this thing say bathing
cap
hairspray war ball if the background I
think is that is that you want you want
a good a good clean background as well
that's probably a Zeiss guys causes a
problem yes I think I hinted to it
earlier on today like mobile net has its
usefulness I use a lot but for teaching
and training practical usefulness it's
iffy cuz it's no it's really not that
accurate like if you really were looking
for one of those things and that image
net if you're looking for whatever it
was called a scuba diver alright one of
them then maybe it's useful for you
oftentimes it's not you maybe want to
use an API one thing is useful for is
something called chance for learning and
we'll leave it for a second so they're
all having fun and be something fun
whatever have fun I can see it I mean if
you want to take pictures of what are
you doing and tweet it and tag jaw ache
you know that would be nice
and if you want to run to take a
screenshots knowing after I mean you can
I mean that every pleasant if you did
Brida happy yeah have to buy sensual
we're doing next somebody nice when
we're doing it I said give me a second
you have fun there let's get set up on
this side
Oh
what did i do what did i do what did i
do what did I do
second figure out what I did
look space
so give me a second I'm just trying to
figure out where my code is
joy development workspace
joy development workspace choice
development work experience
Tietjens work
aggression
yes excellent all right and
all right so
go on
yeah yeah so my bond that is so if you
are on a clean white background it'd be
a little bit more accurate but not
massively you're still fine it's not
gonna so it's good for in terms of
practical use cases that you'll use
today with mobile net in like your real
world No right it's not it's not it's
not good enough for a lot of that stuff
it is good enough for certain things but
it really depends on your use case well
I think the real power of something like
mobile net and I think one of the just
talking broadly really about JavaScript
a machine learning you're not really
going to be training up incredibly
complex things in javascript in the
browser you're just not
it's like single threaded Java scripts
not like the best language doing compute
do a lot of these machine learning
models you need hundreds of servers
running at it for 4 weeks you know but
what it is really good at is Walton but
what is the possibility of a very
interesting use case is something called
transfer learning right for transfer
learning you take an existing model an
existing brain and then this brain
mobile has been has been trained to
recognize one of a thousand things but
during that journey of training it
remember layers each layer in each node
actually if you there's ways of
interrogating a model and seeing well
what does that node what does it really
understand what is it seeing as part of
the image I'm afraid on this I'll have
to get the slides up later on I find
them but they they've when they when
they examine these networks they can see
that actually this node at the start
it's detecting this all it can detect in
an image is this a curve like that or
another no
it learns how to detect a corner and in
the next layer
maybe they determine one one node has
figured out how to see if something's in
ear right and then that very at the end
then you decide oh this is a face right
or cat or dog or something like that
what you can do is you can kind of
lobotomize the last layer and you
retrain it to learn something else
because if you've got if you've got a
model that already knows how to detect
edges corners
maybe colors if it's learned something
you can then retrain it to retrain to
detect other things go friend who use
mobile net and it's called transfer
learning and that last layer learning
just trained the last layer doesn't
require as much computation as training
the whole model from scratch so it's
possible to do that stuff in JavaScript
possible sometimes in the browser so
that's where I think mobile net is
useful for okay it's not detecting a lot
of very clever things but on the lower
levels of that of that of a model it's
detecting something's like a baby you
know it's like learn something but you
just need to train the last mile another
way I describe it as is imagine imagine
learning JavaScript from scratch imagine
teaching something JavaScript from
scratch or taking a Python developer and
teaching them JavaScript like the second
one it's not going to be as much effort
and that's kind of transfer learning and
that's where it can start being useful
yeah
Oh
api's you wanna do some really some
really powerful stuff you can get
started straightaway with API if you
only like train stuff up that's bigger
yeah well I can't say categorically you
you won't because maybe there is a use
case where it's actually accurate enough
but yeah typically now like yeah
any of the questions I could not
remember if you look in is it is it not
downloading for you if you look in a
network tab because that because I it's
actually not one JSON file that JSON
file then triggers the loading of some
shard files so if you look at the
network tab you'll see but it's many
megabytes small
so to get start with the regression
clone this bad boy bad boy it's not
that's not good bad person
[Music]
okay
train the mouth begin the brown hoodie
trading on the server come up with the
new
if it's very very simple and maybe you
can get away with something in there in
the browser I know I think I was talking
to earlier on but he did stuff in in
node on on the server side because it
just just a computer up but yeah you can
still it's doable in JavaScript yeah I
think the is good to play around the
stuff in the browser because you've cz
to play around with but then if you need
to get a little bit more computing you
want to stay in JavaScript you can use a
node.js version or tensorflow then if
you really want to go for that you can
rewrite it in there in there yeah I for
learning and right now just for
inferring in the browser mean yeah
mostly just for inferring it's like yeah
yeah I don't know it's difficult to know
really and what people are really using
it for but yeah all right
did we cloned it he hasn't cloned it
that's a terrible question who hasn't
find it we're all good excellent so
questions also different types of
regression we're looking at linear
regression which is kind of maybe you
remember this stuff you got a hot you've
got a whole bunch of dots points and you
want to find the best fit line between
them kind of what is the linear
relationship between these two sets of
data logistic regression which is more
Honor that's polynomial they listed we
just we have polynomial regression which
is kind of a similar thing as linear
regression except you you understand
that the relationship is is nonlinear
right like
yeah we've got logistic regression which
is more to do with probabilities we're
not only going to that so for instance
this is a famous one sir cricket chirps
per minute and ambient temperature so
that's actually has a linear
relationship
I suppose up until they die right
I puts all their dead but up until then
it's a linear relationship Fame some
more temperature is the more cricket
chirps per minute oh yeah my friends so
extrapolating this data can be a problem
sometimes right so you need to take it
with a pinch like you need to understand
your data understand where where might
have a linear relationship and where it
might not remember this remember this
yeah yeah there we go back a school
machine learning is maths its maths
there's just no way around it I'm no
good at maths so it's a real struggle
for me and I'm very very lucky that I've
got a lot of friends who know this base
you are willing to to spend time with me
to tell me bigger stuff RBIs maths right
you do have to get to get to know quite
well anyway this is this is the this
little an equation that describes a line
so why the position on the y coordinate
of the line is equal to M some variable
M times X plus B now B would be if X is
zero so it would be zero so that would
mean B is 5 a right that's the constant
remember this stuff I feel so clever
remember all this stuff from school but
that's basically it and that's what we
want to do here so you've got you've got
you've got this whole bunch of data sets
of points and you all know the linear
relationship is between them all right
this is how you do
okay oh and why linear regression is a
really good start to get to understand
how to do in your networks just because
of this right this is a neuron the same
thing we had before we have X imagine
your x and y coordinate of your point is
you your expected value and your your
input value all right so your feature
and what you expect it's kind of like
having labeled data our training set so
you can train on and then your m and B
what what what do we really want to do
is you what you want something that will
figure out given a set of points which
is your data set the best fit line so
you really want to shoot it's going to
tune some valleys for it for M and B
that's what you're gonna be doing that's
why linear regressions are good a good
first step to understand how to build
neural networks because it's gonna teach
you this it's just one neuron it's me so
hard to get it's one neuron right then
once you've got this right you can apply
it to all of them and join them all
together all right I forgot I actually
and we're supposed to show you a demo
let me show you a demo oh no I didn't ah
cover I see this is basically something
that what we're gonna build right is
we're going to build today see as you
add points it's gonna figure out what
the line is and what that line is
figuring out basically an M and a value
for M and a value for B that's basically
where it's gonna figure out and it's
gonna automatically figure out what
those are from your data sets that's it
all right
I think I skipped the slide let me go
let me go through this again so don't
skip anything so yeah and so then let's
say we gave it a value X 1 and Y 16 it
then figures out let's just say what
have I done here what is this maths oh
my god
MX plus B yes right so if we gave a
value of x is equal to 1 M is 4 B is 12
y is equal to MX plus b MX is 1 times 4
4 plus B is 12 y is equal to 16
that's all where this neuron would give
us however we know because it's our
point that we created the X is equal to
1 and Y is equal to 13 so we know that
the values here are wrong the optimizer
is gonna run and it's going to retune
these things to another slide
we tune those things to be better value
and this thing here is called a loss
function this is the most important part
of it used to describe how wrong you are
need a function that tells you how wrong
you are
that's what it's all about and that's
what I'm great
okay all right
so hopefully you should have a folder
that looks a little bit like this yeah
good create one as main dejay so just
just just create it and that's why
you're gonna type stuff in because all
these all these other ones are is just
different bits of code that you can use
okay so cool that you can use to figure
out that you can go to write so we're
going to go through kind of 1 2 3 etc
etc at the end I want to show you linear
regression and then you're gonna figure
out all by yourself you're gonna figure
out how to do polynomial regression so
you gonna figure out all right oh yeah I
checked in 10 so jess library in the
source code that's how I code yeah I
check independent libraries into github
yeah no one thought that before I
thought of it okay obviously don't do
that if you're doing it in flux when I
use that use the official version if I
just checked in to make things simple
we're also using a library called p5.js
I'm gonna go through that very very
briefly so you can see how it works it's
a visualization library who here is the
react developer view angular alright
Hugh p5.js is not like that at all right
do not use p5.js do not use in
production you want to see why in a
second you should never ever use p5.js
in production it's just I'm it's an
interesting way to draw stuff assist
it's used a lot in teaching younger
people and I just think want to get
stuck I just don't wanna have an
argument about a web framework
I just didn't want to have that
discussion so use paper at p5.js I'm
also going to use a main digestible
because we're just going to stick
everything in I call our bar all of our
code as we as we code along and I'm
gonna do things today as I'm gonna go
for this one experiment a little bit I'm
gonna go through things I had some
feedback from the last time I gave this
workshop I'm gonna try and go through
things in a different order fingers
crossed this will work but it should
hopefully be a lot more engaging for you
all as you go through
so right now you should have those in
this index they station file make sure
you've got a main digest and make sure
you've got it here and it exists let me
actually rename mine I mean just one and
I'm going to just empty this one out
right and then however you or whenever
well you'll did it with the mobile net
so I presume you'll know how to open up
the thing yeah each opening with a pin
in it and I'm using live server plug-in
but if you serve or whatever else that
you're using locally go for it
and then that's it well nothing should
be there because it should be it's just
your main dodge s is blank I think I'm
missing something in a second
I'm missing explaining something am i no
nothing I'm good yeah
ya think I'm with alright so we're gonna
go through peafowl jess super quickly
it's a p5.js
is amazing it uses Global's everywhere
so everything you've been taught about
Global's are bad is wrong Global's are
amazing okay so what happens is is that
is that basically if there's two
functions available called setup and
draw that's what it will call right so
it's expecting these functions of these
specific names to be available so setup
is called before anything helps you set
up things and draw is called well let's
figure out when draw is called let's
just see all right so it's just a copy
and if you want you can just copy and
paste it from set the blood draw put in
your main j/s and it's safe right
and then open up in the browser boom
yeah you see that
this is probably why you shouldn't use
p5.js in production right because it
just it just draws as fast as possible
continue constantly that's it basically
right pretty cool I think even does it
this too even when it no no I think with
chrome when you're not looking on the
screen it doesn't draw it on I still
draws it yeah that's basically how what
happens and you you're gonna there's
gonna be drawing logic that you're gonna
stick and draw right on the set of
budget stick and set up the main thing
you want to do is you want to create
canvas area which is where you should
draw stuff so if you go to to canvas dot
color you can grab that for that line
from setup dot the set up there and copy
into your main okay create canvas again
another wonderful global I think oh
there's other things it's not giving us
window width and window height another
Global's Y is a coding not like this why
don't we do it like this is so much fun
right basic this is the window the width
and the height of the window we've seen
create canvas it's ledger craying a
html5 canvas the full size of the screen
and once you've got a canvas you can do
fun stuff like you can set the
background just to the background
right I don't know what color that is
maybe it's gray it's red red green and
blue that's all that is or you can
actually if you wanted to you could kind
of well let's just see it working first
and again what is that doing right now
every time draw is called is painting
the whole thing every single pixel that
color right drawing it from scratch it's
gonna do it every frame I can't remember
try out I think you got to put it in
draw anyway you need it in draw because
if you draw a line it doesn't disappear
you've got a paint over everything again
and draw it all again right it's great
it's fun though it's fun this is how
coding should be or you can do like read
something out nice
so you can set a background and I think
this is the point where I'm going to
jump ahead
so again
oh you know you know paper people dress
no loop yeah I think I'm good with it
with a capital L yeah and it stops a
looping yeah boom and then loop right
Luke just stop looping well let's just
see
yeah this is why it's so much fun yeah
it just works right you just try it
typed okay don't use no loop let it loop
let it loop let it loop and I think this
is the point where I'm going to be gonna
skip ahead hang on let's get three four
or five or go over very fast I'll go
over it very fast three you can have a
look at if you want later on but this is
how you draw texts you define a fill
color this is almost just like it's all
sequential I know with Jarvis it's all
about callbacks and stuff but this stuff
is just sequential what is the color of
the of the pen what is the font I want
to use from this point onwards or is it
tech sighs I want to use from this point
onwards draw the text hello world in
this position x and y x is at the bottom
why is it the y0 is the bottom no top
let's figure out if you want to see yes
let's do actually and i can copy and
paste that into my draw function
there yeah hello world allagash AB don't
like ice cream
I mean I'm intolerant to milk protein
not like those nuts protein very bad for
me and also bricks it supporters just
two things and I'm lost now I'm lost I'm
lost for my any one of us to be yes
three four five I Sayed your text you
can also draw shapes if you're doing if
you used to kind of like drawing tools
that can you set a stroke wait
the stroke color you can draw an ellipse
of this X&Y I'm this size and then you
can say from this point I was almost no
stroke right so that's I'm gonna do here
as well just gonna have these drop in
there okay I'm just going to draw a
circle in the center of the screen
theoretically in the center of the
screen because it's window width / -
window height / - right
let's see let's go to that let's go to
that let's do that
let's give it up man boom very very
faint circle why is it that color I
don't know
Oh cuz happens that they lost the
background let's set the background
background background background oh my
god I just feel great
GRE why or a why a is other both valid
are you serious
have you just like blowing my mind
no wait I have both valid was that the
same shade
it's the same if I just learned
something I feel I should have known
this already by now I didn't know that
okay excellent
I'm the stroke I said the stroke to like
red or something like that you can do
this yeah so you can draw circles right
Riley feels I should have known that
why the center why I think I must have
said it
Oh interesting I think that's the film
the film must be white by default if I
set fill to bloom a fill oh my god how
do I not do that escape yeah blue
but the makings of my next website right
here alright color color selection
spot-on
the next thing I was going to skip over
was five on lines okay did I go over
lines no didn't so lines is coming very
similar
you just have a line that you can draw
in fact let's just draw a line in the
middle of it let's not go nuts so a line
X Y to begin X Y to end another x1 y1
your x1 y1 x2 y2 so 10 just should be
kind of going no that way down I think
yeah
so the X&Y is top left which is really
annoying when you join graphs on lines
because you want you want the Y to be
here what Y is there to be there baby
that draws a line boom you can draw a
line
all right
okay and now I'm gonna skip to seven
boom
okay cool things you can do a game
loving the Global's you gotta embrace
the Global's okay they're great they're
fantastic if a function called
mouseclicked exists guess when it's
called every time the mouse is clicked
why's life why is it not this simple
simple right mouse clicks Mouse X and
Mouse why are helpfully set to the x and
y position of the mouse at the moment
that it was clicked
then you can set draw a circle at that
position of radius 10 let's just copy
and paste that in fact I'm going to get
rid of my get rid of my draw function
just to clear out oh no oh no oh god
sakes boom
and Adam mouseclicked this is it and
huge will copy and paste this you can
pop copy and paste it from seven
mouseclicked right then that's it now if
I go here yes you should be able to now
do this all over the screen pretty cool
hey pretty cool view now you started to
like p5.js aren't you yeah yeah my
wandering and mines trying to think of
ways you can release this in production
you can't don't write
they go
you're a second
to try and get out while I frantically
remember more the next thing is
okay
hopefully you're all working on that
what I want you to do want to give you a
little bit time now to focus on this
create two variables that are am i
letting these am i letting these I'm on
let's let them yeah let oh my god
X's all right
but wise right I just want you to every
time the mouse is clicked through this
X&Y just start collecting them collect
all the x's and the X is irate but all
the Y's in the wiser right just do that
it's getting gentle gentle instruction
[Music]
Oh
so I'm just
hopefully wasn't too too difficult if
this is how this is all this is this is
all you should hopefully have needed to
do X is that push Mouse X
why's that push and that's why okay
let's not bother drawing it for our so
that's it right in fact I can just
[Music]
it's a clever way of writing all this
stuff isn't it like you use a D
structure or something and then
man I'm tell me if I'm being an idiot
what am i doing right now
okay does this work man how am I even
doing how am I even thinking right now
is that thing that thing can do that
well that's it if this works I'm gonna
be I'm happy okay okay okay okay it's
working so that's basically creating me
two arrays one with all the X values and
one with all the all all the what is it
how comes Tony going printing one
actually printing - here we go is - one
- right okay X's and Y's right however
you can see it so she's storing in like
the actual x and y of the position in
the screen on my screen might be
different to your screen so a lot of the
time when we're doing with stuff with
machine learning what we want to do is
we want to normalize our date and you
usually want to normalize it to between
zero and one that's kind of a really
good thing to do keep everything
normalized between zero and one so if
you know the width of your screen you
know that you clicked kind of there then
that's probably probably bout 75% or
0.75
well p5.js has it like a nice function
that allows you to to do that and that's
called math okay and with map what it
does
I'm just gonna copy and paste the whole
thing
the Africa
so what map does is it kind of Maps a
value from one range to another range so
what this is saying if you've got the
number 500 that rain that comes from a
range of 0 to 1000 and I want to map it
to a range of 0 to 1 right it's just
gonna normalize it to 0 to 1 Sophie if I
actually now if you look at that printed
out or shizzle we're just done it's been
0.5 okay
what we want to do is want to use the
window width because depending on where
you clicked in the window width you want
it to say that be 1 that be 0 I'm gonna
normalize on number this is just a
standard thing you want to do in machine
learning with your datasets you want to
normalize everything observe to 1 so
given that given that's how map works
all right
normalize the X's the XS and the Y's so
that it's storing a value from 0 to 1
instead of 100 150 something like that
you got me the helpful variables you
want it you want is window width and
window height right there's two clues
I'm giving you right
it's a map window with window height if
you want to see other examples of map
working you can look in 6 dot map but
j/s there's lots of examples there to
play around with but that's basically
what we want to do here
give you a few minutes
we're not you haven't touched on
tensorflow yet have we
right I know I know we're getting there
again as I said previously you wanna
remember those moments when you were
just drawing circles on it on a page
remember it fondly
okay
alright I'll just show you I give the
answer so basically how you would make
that work would be this and what I'm
really doing is I'm we're gonna we are
going to start I'm not gonna I'm showing
you enough of the codes that later on
when you need to when you need to start
changing some of the stuff you stopped
you kind of know what you're looking at
but in terms of drawing the drawing
drawing stuff and in terms of getting
data in the right way so if you want to
normalize the X's okay we're going to
push X the input is Mouse X between zero
and Max and Max from the X is going to
be the width it's just when your window
width right and then we want it we want
it to map from zero to window width to 0
to 1 same thing goes for the Y's Mouse Y
but this time it's window height
okay that's the map that's the
usefulness of the map function so now
you go to what's calling me
so now wait ah I should stop it stop it
printing out other stuff why is it
printing it like here again
okay so now if I should click it there
it should be zero zero close to it
yeah zero if I click it right to the end
there it should be near like one 4x
yeah yeah this is the second one I'm a
big bomb right it should be almost 1:1
yeah Sumbul point nine nine no point
nine seven four so we've just kind of
normalized everything from zero to one
all right if you look in the functions
packet line no calculate collect points
which is kind of it that click pointers
is where we're going towards what what
we should end up with you can see I've
actually got some functions here and all
they are is just a map function but
we're just kind of created a help of
helpful versions of them to do the same
thing so norm just saved him having to
write all of that stuff yourself so if I
put it here
just paste them at the top like that so
with these all this is doing is calling
map be providing in the max and norm X
is just doing the same thing where it's
just giving you window width so with
these helper functions you can replace
this with just norm X and norm Y that's
all that those functions are doing so
don't be scared of this function the top
all they're doing is what you just did
for in just fewer characters right
hopefully let's see if that works yes oh
my god so good at this coding stuff
should be paid for you
yeah actually look at collect points
that's that's all I'm doing
we should be basically here wow that's
how you do that's a clever way of doing
it there you go
yeah so now let's look at let's take a
look at map points between lines so I
think I explained lines very briefly
before so you have a line x1 y1 x2 y2
before I showed you the equation of a
line remember that y is equal to MX plus
B for some reason I don't in a coder
then changed it to Y is equal to ax plus
C and I must have had a reason so oh and
they shouldn't be constants so all I'm
gonna do is at the top of my here I'm
going to add another few let's let a
let's see okay there's just two values
and then I'm gonna create a function
which you're gonna give me a value of y
given a value of x right oh ok so get Y
given some value of x this is just MX
plus C but for some reason and I cannot
figure out oh I remember now why yeah
hang on boy
I used a a X plus C that's all that's
doing all right
that's all that's doing so
given that given that this is some new
information that you've got given that
you know how to draw a line can you draw
this line you know this is a line and
they should have it should look like
that or it should look like that or
maybe it looks like that you don't know
draw this line on the screen and where X
is zero here X is a window width on the
other side that should give you X 1 X 2
and the function should give you the Y's
then you should be able to join to two
dots together it's got me yeah try doing
that try using this function to draw a
line on the screen
any line and yet let me ask you to draw
the draw function
you're very close to starting to write
some tensorflow code I promise very
close very close
give you another minute or so
Wow
yeah I thought all right I want to draw
a line now on the screen it's going to
be legendary so what do you want to do
let's get let's go next one
where's the x1 gonna be from the
furthest left of the screen so it's
going to be zero let's get a y1 okay so
what is the YY given the value of x well
we've gotten that we've got a nice
function above called get Y let's just
call it get Y x1 hey yeah
now we've gone x1 and a y1 let's get
next to x2 is equal to the furthest
right of the screen window width let's
get Const Y to get Y x2 boom now we have
an x1 y1 x2 y2 and then let's draw a
line let's give it a stroke
what's the
hmm
unless Kurdish a wait to get some you
know weightiness thickness and then
let's draw our line so ah what new line
x1 y1 x2 y2 boom
this should hopefully
ha
draw stroke stroke red
what I done wrong ah I've got to draw
functions the beauty of Global's there
you go to draw functions right one
overrides the other one right boom okay
a Geordie delighted and if you wanted to
do if you want to change what you're
drawing what you're the line you can
just change it here so you can change
that to 0.5 0.5 0.5 and it changes the
line it gets drawn right - - and you can
change this to 300 all right so now
we've created some of the draws a line
based off of that equation that we have
that we had before right so given that
let me get back to where we were one 150
Conner what was it something like that
nope I'm fine
that's the line so I've also got this
thing at the bottom I'm still got mine
there where is it here I'm gonna just
want to still draw the circle give me a
second ellipse
okay
I must give a straight way of like
really black
okay now go this line here you've also
got this data point here okay remember
we need to figure out the loss like how
wrong is this line if if all my circles
were here would that be a big loss
number or a small loss number
small/small right
if all my points were here but yet it
drew a line here would that be a large
or small loss large loss exactly right
that's what we need to calculate we need
a way of knowing how far how wrong it is
and we use something called a common one
we use it's used all the way through
you'll see all the time machine learning
is mean squared error okay mean squared
error and you you could get away with
like ages maps using mean squared error
and a lot of things because it's just
it's a good loss function to use
generally for for machine learning so
what this says is given given some value
so given this value of x here
you get this is this is the actual value
and this is 1 and this is 1 and yet
however if you to look on the equation
it would kind of give you these numbers
here so you figure out the distance okay
but you square it on man
this is where the jet LAG's really gonna
kick in for a second I need Corrections
if anyone's correct me correct me you
square it and then you divide it all by
the means you want you end up with one
number okay the reason you square is
because sometimes you might get a
negative number
yeah and you need it to kind of you
don't care about the signage you don't
care the direction it is wrong right
that's why you square things and that's
basically what we want to to do now is
you need to calculate the loss it's
super important to understand your loss
it's super important because number
everything I showed you like it needs to
know tents flow needs to know how wrong
something is in order to tune something
so that's all we're going to do now
and in fact if you go to I'm gonna write
this out yes
no man it's gonna be dangerous if I
write this out I'm gonna copy and paste
I'm sorry I'll just go through it line
by line
yes
so the same code you saw before same
stuff you did before mouse clicks you
don't you've done all this before you're
storing everything in X's and Y's and
then you call loss remember our ANC is
fixed here right now what happens I need
to call loss each of the X's okay you
get the x and y we then pass it through
you kind of need to do this kind of take
the zero to one value I know you don't
need to do that anyway that's all I did
you basically get the Y value you take
the difference
okay but might be negative you square it
you sum it all together you divided by
all the X's all the values and you get
like a little something called a loss
and print it out right and I've actually
got in the rest of the code here he
copied and pasted the code from Target
loss you'll see that I'm actually
drawing that loss value on the screen
I'm drawing it on the screen okay as
text so that's all that's the only real
difference between this and your other
code before that's it just calculating a
loss value all right so that I now load
this up in the browser this is what you
see and if I draw as if I click here if
I add it there's no there's no X's of
X's and Y's max I don't add anything if
I add one close to it our fingers
crossed
yes the loss is low right the loss is
very low if I hopefully start doing it
away so loss increases and now if I add
some more data points closer to it a
loss reduces right that's what's going
on
and so what imagine this is our data
here this is that this is our actual
data like something like this the lines
wrong the liens wrong but now you have a
number that describes exactly how wrong
it is and tend to flow then uses that
loss to figure out how to adjust the a
in the C that's all you need to do is
you need to find the right value of a
and C so it fits perfectly in all those
dots that's all what we're doing here is
we're tuning that value of a and C
that's all we're doing that's a magic of
tensorflow it's not really the magic
it's nothing you right now you're like
is this it this is it this is it this is
all the machine learning is
right
okay
I'm gonna hit tensorflow before we hit
tens of Thor we have to hit maths
max right matrices go let's go there
matrix maths big deep
big I wanted to get some food hang on
what I want not food
what's the other stuff that you get it's
not food so coffee they don't want to
come think white a coffee
yeah okay matrix maths simple
two-dimensional matrixes matrices okay
just go remember this stuff back before
back back back when when you're kind of
adding kind of matrices together this is
it as long as the same same size and
shape you just kind of add the
appropriate stuff together and it gives
you the the output matrix okay
skip broadcasting deniable that why do I
have this oh sorry I do have this
transposing takes a matrix books on a
side right subtraction can the same as
that pair element-wise subtraction
memorize it
same as addition just take me
appropriate one away I didn't draw this
one properly I just didn't have just in
dirt you can figure out division same as
normal he's kind of take that divided by
that that one divided by that one it's
kind of element-wise it kind of goes
that way you're not just multiplied by
constant all the way through but
multiplies all of it together and then
you don't do what's called multi element
wise multiplication which is 1 times 2
and this one is 2 times 3 just 6 3 times
4 12 4 times 5 20 but I want to quickly
go through these and you're gonna go
through some examples in tensorflow or
you have this in your head and then you
can add you're going through the
examples intensified it's sort of stuff
hopefully will will go through and you
also have this thing called the dot
products which allows you to do kind of
like a zipping up maybe that's the best
way of describing it so if you've got
two ones of the opposite shapes you can
kind of zip through so all of this row
plus all multiplied and then plus all of
that row and add it up together is equal
to that and that equals that goes that
way dot products
no I see on examples I'm going to show
you now is have to do all of those
intensive flow because you don't need to
know that so open up no tip 10a ah man
wait
yes okay okay in this file you're gonna
just see these things called quiz under
the quiz you're gonna see the single
answer don't scroll to the answer give
it a go it's just just try to think I'm
mad just just give it a go try it out
right don't scroll all the way to the
answer Oh
I'm just going to stop
copying these into my main in fact I
will just get rid of all of this okay so
this how you create a one-dimensional
array a 1d tensor in tensor flow certeyn
once you want you to attend to flow all
that tensor is is just a race right you
can have a scalar which is kind of one
value this is a 1d tensor which is what
you'd normally call just like an array a
2d a second rank tensor is a
two-dimensional array then you get three
third dimensional fourth dimensional
fifth dimensional signal you can go
crazy deep in terms of dimensions and it
gets really hard to visualize so that's
why using something called rank and
shape is useful so if I now print this
what you'll see is Oh
why they're not printing the rank and
the shape
console.log
I don't know why that's not printing out
can I see well let's not print oh yeah
this printing out just above oh sorry it
is printing out so this shape the rank
is one because it's 1d and the shape is
three because just the length of three
it's just the 1d array with the length
of three so it tells you the shape and
then what you can do is a dot print you
can't do console.log a and annoying
whether you go to a dot print and that
prints you out kind of a visual look at
the tensor if you are printing something
crazy long a dot print is nice because
it only prints some of it it doesn't
kill your console that's why it's useful
if you do want to make it kind of
clearer you can just you know say ten to
one D and it will try or give you an
error if you give it something other
than one B if you don't provide the one
day it will try and figure out what it
is from the day that you're giving it
okay
the other thing
and then you can give it like a
different shape so now we're gonna give
it a 2d array there do you know what I'm
gonna just paste it here okay then so
now I'm giving you a 2d two-dimensional
array 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 so this is
a rank 2 because it's 2 dimensional this
helps so we're only being with 2
dimensionals right now so it's useful
when you do it with 3 4 or 5 you need to
know this stuff and the shape is 2x2 2x2
but when you print 2 hours printing out
like that
less tensors let me open up on the other
screen so I can just copy and pastes
[Music]
another way you can do it is you can
just give it a flat you can give it as
one two three four just as a 1d array
and then you can say actually I'm going
to give you as a flat array but the
actual shape is two by two you can do
that way if you want and that's useful
very useful especially when you're
loading of tons of data and you're
stored it as one CSV file and you can
load it up and go here it is by the way
this is the actual n shape don't bother
you'd have to reformat it into the right
shape before you give it anything you go
it's just on that now we have a quiz now
we have a quiz yes we have a quiz right
make a oh no answers don't go to the
answers make a rank one tensor of four
five six and by rank 1 tensor which is
the 1d array 406 and then a rank two
tensor look how that's laid out four
five six what does that mean call them
four five six then a rank three tensor
three dimensional what yeah rank three
or Fuzzle oh my god four or five six
that way look at those brackets
insane right try to out
[Music]
all right
I'm gonna go for it let's give it a go
oh maybe maybe I'll give you a second
all right let's go let's go for it
all right so we have
so the question was let me copy and
paste the question make a rank make a
Rank 1 tensor four five six let's try
that there's a couple different ways you
can do that you can just just type out
of this four by six pretty simple let's
print it out as well five six boom boom
four five six there you go simple simple
is you can do other ways you can hit
font if you want to do you could do 1d
and a bit bit bit bit bit of a that's
not ten it's not type-checking it's kind
of its kind of type checking but not
really or if you didn't really want to
be completely specific you could then
say give it a shape and the shape is
three you want to be really specific
write a rank two tensor so for that one
you would basically do well you could
literally just give it this all right
I'm gonna figure the rest out or all
right oh no it won't
that way
fingers crossed
as I wanted
yes I want it yeah four of six column
four five six right but again you can
see the shape there is three one okay
three rows of one value in each row so
if you wanted to you could be you could
give it like this four five six with a
3-1 give you that way
same difference
okay what the hell is this what's this
oh my god
let's give it go
what is even this what does this even
look like like how can you visualize
this I haven't it's just another
dimension I even visualize it it's
insane basically this is it uh where I
do one more
a daughter my daughter was doing her
homework the other day
this starts just like to do a computer
science like she's 13 so that it could
be a science at school she's like I say
oh what stopped working I looked at her
and she'd like missed out some brackets
and yeah missed up some brackets I don't
know what I missed out the brackets
she put the brackets in and it worked my
wife's a program as well and I said I'll
doors just got her first bracket Sarah
right it's imagine that the first time
it's right there rest of her life she's
gonna get a million of those is there
for the first time anyway so that's what
it looks like but still like how do you
visualize it it's kind of like how what
does it even mean like um this is all
the shapes getting become even more
useful now because it's like three are
they even columns I don't know to call
them three thing Leia yeah three layers
three Zed's it's like another thing so
that's the shape three of something and
then each of those things has one of
something and each of those things has
one of something right you have to start
thinking in this way
remember mobile net yeah I told you yeah
melon that was fun times Neville there
wasn't it yeah I was good stuff good
stuff and then yeah and that's that okay
you can do other things so you can
transpose a matrix
let's do it here
what does three-dimensional matrix look
like when it's transposed I don't know
let's find out let's find out
I know yeah
it looks like that
Wow yeah I feel if we did this in A to D
thing that might make a little more
sense you can visualize that a little
bit better
we're getting there I swear we're
getting somewhere
we're close right zip this is four five
six would then go either way
transpose you can add things together
let's go here okay all right two tensors
we all know what this is doing now this
is turning this into a two dimensional
tensor to the two and this isn't just
another way of describing a two
dimensional tensor we can add a add B
and then print it out and that's it
that's doing the element wise addition
that we showed before we can also do
something and this is kind of more
tensor Fleury than anything else this is
not problem matrix and multiplication
but you can broad call you can use broad
they're a little broadcast which is
where if some data is missing it will
extrapolate it extrapolate it repeat it
for you automatically sand normally we
doing addition you would and then a is a
two-dimensional like one to four values
the thing you add it to has to have four
values we can just give it one value and
it will go there I'll copy it four times
it's called broadcasting we're going to
use an example of that and that's what
works that did that broadcast eight
three eight four six last one should be
ten yeah i broadcast it and
you can also do subtraction as well as
addition it's the same wage before so a
subtract be the same as addition you can
also do division
I'm going to skip the out we're going to
need it and then you can also multiply
same ways do before multiply by constant
a mole to print there we go
multiplied and you can also
[Music]
multiplied by another matrix I think I'm
gonna skip the rest I think this is all
you need for this particular example
this is doing the same thing is just
before system e 1 times 2 then 2 times 3
and 3 times 4 then 4 times 5 that's what
should print out the last one should be
20
I don't think we need to know do the
rest okay hopefully if I if I skipped
enough I skip the right stuff that
should be all the matrix maths you need
to know in order to do the rest of it
all right
all right
i I'm just going to
[Music]
read read through this am i yeah I want
to get to the point
give me a second
I've lost track of where I am
yeah let me take it from
yeah
let me take the calculator loss
if you take the calculate lost code to
begin with now we are going to start
doing some real tensorflow stuff
are we
I've seen loss
no.not example I'm gonna mess this up
I'm sorry I want to show you how to do
linear regression and we'll go through
it and then I'm gonna ask you to do
polynomial regression yourself okay
I'm gonna mess up some brackets at some
point I don't trust myself right now I'm
just gonna talk through the code I
apologize
well about apologize so this is
basically the same code as we had before
with the lots you can see we've got the
get Y the norm X addy norm Y but we've
now we've got this kind of other section
with some tensorflow stuff but at the
bottom we've got the same stuff account
kinda got a mouse clicks we've got the
drawing drawing the points on the screen
they're drawing a line drawing the loss
it's the same per as you have the
calculus but we've got this kind of tend
to flow a bit at the top what's that
doing all right
you create a suitable variables
these are things that the variables they
can they can change the things you want
to change the a in the C right
we initialize them with a random number
this is our weight store node okay we
then create what's called an optimizer
this is the thing that choose the values
of a and C we give a learning rate
learning rate tells you tells you
optimizer how quickly it should change
or how large it should try and tune
those numbers to get to the right value
okay how what a big jump is gonna make
so if you did not point five it's gonna
maybe try and it's not gonna do not
point five it may be all change each
weight by not point five as you go down
and that may be that will make you train
faster but at the same time maybe you'll
overshoot and grow you the side if you
think about it right so normally you
won't have a get a pretty slow learning
rate like that okay that's the ideal
thing to have I think I've got not point
five there for some other reason if
you're looking at tensorflow
documentation there's lots of different
ones you can use
API or AP OSHA's a month
let's go ahead am i there already I am
there woody yes GD oh man they've
changed the stalks train
yep
ours is proper tensorflow that's why
yeah okay there we go
there's lots of different types of those
optimizers that you can use this is
called stochastic gradient descent
simple one that you can all be can try
and use there's other ones there and you
go through some of the other examples
you can try using some of those for us
right now we're just gonna use to cast
the gradient gradient descent
and then we've kind of got a predict
which is basically just like get why but
for tensorflow it's like get Y button
get Y you could just pass in normal
numbers but now we're dealing with tend
to flows and tenses so we do that matrix
multiplication a dot mole X it's the
valleys it passing in add our C so a is
this a X is actually going to be our
full list of X's so it's basically like
a matrix like an if you've got a hundred
points I'd be a hundred you definitely
passing in in one go but it's being a
matrix multiplication and doing all
those calculations at once in the
predict function and what its going to
give you it's going to give you an array
of results
that's what predict is going to give you
for a given array of X's ten set of X's
it's going to give you a tensor of Y's
you do this this loss function again I'm
that loss function we spoke about before
given the predicted Y's subtract the
actualize mean square I mean squared
error this is how you do mean squared
error intensive flood you've got an
array of Y's my what you've calculated
then you've got the actual Y's that you
clicked you take one from the other you
then get an array all the differences
between those wise so I'm going positive
so I'm gonna be negative so you square
them it's made them more positive then
you take the mean means greater right
they think is just some just a way once
you're dealing with tensors you can't
eat me dot print to actually get the
actual value inside it go use Data Sync
and then this is the actual training
thing this is where it gets tender
framing tensive pretends to flowy so for
a given number of iterations you want to
go through go through all the X's the
current iteration is a current epoch
it's just a normal loop right
I go to TR tally in a second you create
tensor
okaying a one dimensional tensor of all
the x's that's all this is a one D
tensor done before then we're doing a
one D tensor of all the Y's it's just
the normal X's and Y's that you've
collected from the mouse clicks what are
you doing
I miss the whole section which is why
this is going so fast I missed the whole
section I really apologize let's go back
rewind right rewind
that's rewind I knew this is like I was
like I haven't covered this how is this
not normally like this okay
I missed 11 I went straight to 12
I missed 11 right do this
okay let's go start from scratch again
okay let's delete this
that went from like zero to a hundred
like straight that went so yeah I'm
sorry it is gonna go from zero to two
thirty though so y'all say that right
now okay let's create ten supply a
variable name it's a variable that's all
it is something that has a value it has
a value of four point one two we then
can then create an array of one a 1d
array five long of to tttt to do okay
and then just like you saw before we can
perform maths operations
yeah
the wise to do so two x x four point one
two and you get the average of it right
so that should be eight point two four
eight point three four eight point three
four eight point two four eight point
two four you're the average of that
should be a twenty four right yeah okay
that's what that that's what that should
print
let's do res dot print wow I've really
skipped ahead Ben did nine before okay
if I do
okay we're in the lecture today but
numbers they go close enough
a point ago
I had to save that I did didn't I
alright okay and yeah this is this is
why I didn't why I said didn't to
actually get the value of a tensor
that's one we do res dot beta sync okay
so that would return a floating point
array and we're just getting the first
value of it alright so let me ask you a
question
what what would the value we want to
train something here so that the result
of this here is zero yeah
the result of this line here is zero
rs.20 okay what does X have to be for
that to give us zero zero right that's
me zero I want to train this with tents
if I want tend to flow to turn that into
zero for me I want tend to pay to turn
that into zero for me right that's what
we want it to do so we create got I
skipped so much ahead
I was shocking since when we start using
tensorflow okay so we create on
optimizer if we just go straight like
that okay
Creon optimizer oh sorry
it's built it wrong no no optimizer we
start off with that and we're gonna call
first thing I want to do is I'm going to
print out the value of x yeah let's
print out twice
and in between that I wanna call
optimiser but minimize I'm gonna explain
this in a second okay
all right so prints out X it should be
four point one two we want it to we want
the optimizer to minimize some value for
us right minimize the loss this is
always we always want to loss to be less
a lost number to be less will minimize
minimizing a lot always we pass in a
function and that function is basically
going to return it's going to be a
tensor so it's gonna be wise okay it's a
tensor here multiply it by X X is a
variable mean square right so if that's
the same as always squares as well but
anyway that's the same as essentially
this tensorflow knows this isn't this
isn't returning an equation this is Rick
this is returning like the description
of an equation and it knows that X is a
variable so it knows it's not going to
try and change anything in the Y's
because the Y's is just the tensor it's
going to try and optimize those values
it knows that you're returning that
you're giving it an equation where one
of them is a variable so it knows that
it can only tune the variable right
that's what it knows
and it's gonna try and tune it so that
it gets sort of the y's become zero
because if the y's become zero then
that's the lowest working actually go
negative actually but that's why we
square it so I'm going negative so what
does this show here so if we now go into
here you can see there you go
4.2 4.0 9/10 to flow changed value of X
all by itself all by itself because it
new is trying to trying to minimize it
hates loss just trying to minimize a
loss if you change its learning rate to
like five whoa it went completely the
other direction right that's why it's
been that's what the learning rates all
about if you change it to be like that
you change it only a tiny I didn't
change at all that's too much
ain't it tiny tiny amount right so the
learning rate is important they're
learning it learning rates small you're
gonna slowly slowly slowly slowly sort
of get the right answer but it's gonna
take you a while to get there the
learning rate is too big you're gonna
zoom past but then probably overshoot
and go to the size that's choosing a
good learning rate is an important well
yeah yeah it would go negative - yeah
which is why we square it to make it
well yeah worry square it yeah okay well
that's not really that useful because
you're only running it once we need to
keep on doing this until it gets to
where you want it to be and all we do is
wrap it in a loop that's it we just do
it we just do this loads and so this is
what I'm gonna do a for loop like
totally wrong Oh have I got a thingy
why is it not am i messing up tab
Wow
yeah the Oscar I'll just copy paste my
little screen here
nice added too much code who needs that
much code still need that much code and
then there alright so I'm just gonna run
it a thousand times I'm just doing
exactly the same optimizer thing but
warning get a thousand times that's all
I'm doing
and so what it's going to do is it's
just gonna try and tune that number x
over that period of time so now you can
see let's try this let me refresh and
see it's tuning it remember for this was
a thousand oh my god
it's gonna get to zero so let's now
choose something like that maybe we'll
go faster see it's pretty it's gone it's
pretty much gone to zero but eighteen
decimal places right I was pretty fast
that's all the tents those doing for us
I said we tell it some variables we give
it some data we wrap it all in matrices
and tensors and it then goes okay what's
your loss function alright whatever I'm
just going to try and minimize the
variable change of variables so that
this loss is elite is the less it could
be there's at least it could be right
[Music]
okay one thing to note though one thing
we're kind of very very very used to in
JavaScript's is you never have to worry
about memory ever we just know that when
we create something in JavaScript it
takes up some memory on your computer
but javascript knows at some point later
to release that memory back out right we
know that right however tensorflow uses
your GPU your graphics card and your
computer screen interesting actually how
graphics cards work what they allowed
you to kind of parallel arise all that's
going on in an easy way however your
graphics card it doesn't it can't
javascript can't then it just doesn't
know when something's not in use anymore
so it doesn't know to free up memory so
this actually right now has a memory
leak and for kept on running this we'd
run out a memory on the computer so what
you need to do is use a wrap all your
tensorflow code is something called TF
tidy like this and like this all right
what I'd done our brackets errors what
we're done there I'm just going to keep
one yeah there you go
so what this is going to do is it's just
going to tell tens up low whenever this
function ends just delete whatever it is
just to leave all those tensors
automatically alright and that's what TF
will tidy he's doing and that's it
that's densified all right that's what's
going on when you're using the optimizer
it's just changing if it detects a
variable in an equation it's going to
try and optimize it giving some data and
loss function all right let's go back to
where we were before then all right
hopefully now you've got some headspace
there so
I am outside the
[Music]
ah no no I think here sit here it's okay
because it's outside you could do it
inside I suppose but nothing you need to
because you don't need to free it up
this is kind of like at this point
whatever there is delete it I don't
think this is nearly rash maybe this is
creating a separate tensor
maybe
maybe
now let's grab all this okay so I'm
gonna go through this again
and then we're gonna go into polynomials
and you're gonna do all that yourself
right here we go back here a and C
they're variables now because we want
tensorflow to tune them right variables
10 slow Tunes variables we create
optimizer you've seen us before all
right I'm going to train this optimizer
I'm going to go through a loop number of
iterations see if that IV there it is
again we're going to get the X's and Y's
that we've already stored and call
optimize what minimize and it's going to
try and minimize whatever this value is
here whatever this returns is going to
try and minimize that whatever that is
so what do we get so we've got the
actual wise from the things what are the
predicted wise and that's just calling
get Y now that kind of a get y is equal
to MX plus ay Y is equal to ax plus C
that's all this is doing given an array
of X's give us an array wise okay that's
not predicted wise then now we've got a
predicted wise and actual wise we can
get our loss and the list is that like
the kind of mean squared error you saw
it before you take them away all right
and you want this to be as lost that the
least loss as possible okay
and that's it
that's all it's doing and it's going to
change the values of a and C repeatedly
one free throws and truck and then tune
it that's all I'm doing here is I'm
getting the value of a and C out of it
and then that's actually used you'd have
to look at it if you look and draw a
line oh yeah she's in get Y and that's
using a and C - let's change the values
a and C just the drawing function and
the last thing you need to know is TF
that next frame it's running in the
browser so if you're running any kind of
mathematical stuff in the browser it's
just going to mmm take up all the CPU
and it's not going to be able to have a
chance to draw anything so next frame
does it just goes now I've done
something
let yourself draw something on the page
and let me do another iteration to the
loop so that's just that's just for that
that's what next frame does right so if
I now ran this in the browser
yeah fill that fresh the page
Booya this is now that movement that
animation is seeing right now that is
ten slow learning each time it adjusts
the value of a and C it moves it and
these are the iterations that are still
running
all right
I'm the mobile that
mobile net was good wasn't it yeah
sometimes a mobile net right
I know zoomed into that but hopefully
that should be enough information to do
them to do the next challenge for you
okay we have another type of let me get
the there's a file called polynomial
solution don't open it
okay a curve there's another equation to
describe a curved line a line with a cut
curved line a curved curved line that's
just stupid
drum with this one then remember this y
is equal to MX squared but I put ax
squared plus BX plus C slightly more
complicated but that's what describes a
curve right
oshizu and say if looking on the screen
this is the same one this is the
polynomial version you can see it's
drawing a line drawing a curve oh my god
strong a curve
but still the same thing as before is
it's just you're giving it some data
you've you've not just got a and see
you've got a B and C but three variables
a B C not just a and C because you need
to be as well and so what I want you to
do is we just start off copy the code
from 13 up on a polynomial regression
start copy all that into your main dot j
s well this whole bunch of commented out
curl the bottom there yeah anyway and
here
bless you out for polynomial I put some
clues in what some clues in to do if you
see it to do
you've probably got to do something to
do tents
I'm back spelling is terrible ten so for
to do alright to do if only life funny
life was like this funny and you're
given work to do at work to put two dues
Norma know you've got to figure stuff
out in life I've put to do is everywhere
for you
there's just a couple places for to dues
is it give it a go
OSHA's all this should be it to do
[Applause]
okay don't forget that one as if there's
a spare to do at the top line 30 to do
also
but everything else here is enough to
give you the curve so you don't you
don't forget anything else so just flesh
the rest out and you can see here but a
little bit more going on alright give
that a go five minutes telling us
I have a vague memory that every time I
give this there's something I've
forgotten on here which I then pretend
was a trick question to keep you all on
your toes so we'll see maybe is a trick
question
well while you're doing that I'm going
to turn myself into it into a meme okay
ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry say again yeah yeah yeah you can
do it you can do that where you go you
can do you can just play around or they
start with a low one and if you don't if
it's not converging pick a bigger one
right down Oh
no because you said that you're setting
up the optimizer before you're running
it through you could probably do
something clever with batching or
something like that bro yeah
huh yeah yeah normal yeah yeah
you don't know yet all right
so some people want to chill so I'll
just go through the answer let people go
off do all that stuff all right okay I'm
gonna go through the answer they all go
we needn't need a variable ABC so much
going to throw another one here let B
equals two right
my spelling is terrible so we need
another way of calculating why is ax
plus C sweet a times oh man I should
plus B times I want to look prettier
figure this out for me yes the a a
squared plus BX plus C tensorflow needs
another variable a b c okay it's going
to tune another value there this is that
it's probably the complex Warner he
might go stuck on this in fact I can't
remember all of this yeah which means
another way of calculating that
candidates this is the get y but for
intensive flow world so how did you
define that there's basically a
multiplied x squared all right add Oh AB
B multiply X let's see oh that's II kind
of like
tend to float up then how last thing
want to do is just store it so it will
then render on the page does that work I
don't know let's see let's figure it out
yeah they're working think it's working
that's not working then we get that yeah
we'll go ahead
really yes I taught people tend to blow
that's it
there we go if you want to go and learn
a bit more unfortunately I don't have it
in a really good format but the very
next thing if I was teaching this a
longer version of this workshop you
would go to the repo but the bitter
bitter bitter bear
No oh god jump straight into that maybe
it was trying to it oh sure and NIST's
was just the same thing em nests so me
rate might be tough for you to follow
without but like seeing it but he did
the next thing i will show you is how to
use em this is a data set where you can
I'll show you
so it's a dataset where you're gonna
wear you can wear as eventually I'll
finish my sentence
shut up my here yeah hopefully I don't
need to do anything
okay this is the next example if you
don't wanna learn it the next to the
next step the next step whole step
hopefully works doesn't look like it's
working oh it's working yeah
and this basically is training up to
wrecking the is where you kind of pull a
lot of stuff together and learn how to
oh my god I am ruined right now
recognize handwritten digits the M this
data set is a famous data set of lots of
lots of handwritten digits it's very
open data set it's kind of a famous
example and what this would allow you to
do after it has finished working is
right now it's training up on all tons
and tons of images of handwritten digits
learning how to recognize handwritten
digits and then you can then use it I
can make this faster wait because I'm
using
oh I know I'm doing the convolutional
model dense model dense model
okay let's try it on the same train
yeah I'm using a simpler training model
okay and you can put a number
I'm off the bottom of the screen just
how can I wait I know I'll trick it into
how about that Hey
it this is - you can't see it on the
bottom but it's - its - right it's - and
like this this is not going to be right
because it gets one wrong all the time
and this is like eight will be like hair
or something there you go
so no wait if I did it like if I did it
for me yeah i refreshed it now yeah
boom - so she's telling your probability
that it thinks it's - so this is kind of
very the next step and this actually
does use more than one neuron and in
that in the example on github which is
gone
let's get have gone oh here's this one's
done a bit differently it's completed
and master master kappa master started
and completed is the end and you'll see
here there's a built with a couple of
different ways of building it a couple
of different algorithms basically so you
can have a look at that see how it works
it's kind of very well-documented the
one you might want to the mont
we're gonna start off with dents I don't
know it's really quite difficult for you
to follow it follow it from there but if
you didn't want to kind of flesh it out
a little bit further that's probably
where I would start all like sand off my
book yeah did you sign up my book well
we'll see I'll check the numbers tonight
see it's out of the book because I'm
gonna try and write all the stuff up
because it's a little bit all over the
place gonna write it all up into a into
a book which I'll then release then you
can you can you can learn it a lot more
you sign up on
but everything that
and a hundred
let's look at another conference
recently was 1400 in the crowd I was
like really excited but reached a
hundred I'd like for sign ups wasn't
really upset I like you know but hey
maybe maybe I'll reach a hundred now I
know and I want to Kickstarter I meet
that I made the cover
you made the cover that's a good one
right it's the robot I made that why
they made that my designer friend made
it but um I just want the book because
it's a good cover look at it it's cute
my little robot all right sorry
well it would draw every second so like
you'll be trying to move the mouse to
the sign up input field gonna be so slow
I am this away from you I knew when the
people who really want it you see that's
it yeah I say we're done thank you wait
wait wait you're gonna have to fill in
the survey form no one leave everybody
stays okay in two seconds
no one leaves
no leaves no leaves
how do you quickly copy I've forgotten
how'd you copy
Jacob a river we are in a yes from Asia
boo boo boo boom
there we go
preview boom boom and then huh but I'll
forget about tile doom I don't buy the
title right and then where's this like
was it slack
just like there's most like there you go
right open the slack do now
once you click it you see the sign up
for the forum where the objectives of
the workshop clearly explained no is one
yes is five did the workshop meet your
expectations not well one very well five
it's weird when I go through the forum I
get so many people filling it out when I
just dropped the link no one I have to
go through the forum was the workshop
too easy too too complex or just right
so one is too complex five is too easy
I'm guessing where that one might might
might land here's the just one if you
ask to get a five-minute presentation
but tends to flow just a five-minute one
how confident are you they could present
this in your work or something
I must go through two applications today
but anyway did you go through too many
or too few can tell me one thing you
like to have a workshop it's the only
goodness I get but no sooner goes the
most important thing is what what what
should I change about the workshop like
what is it something I should change I'd
you saw some of the things I changed
this time around to kind of make a
little bit more engaging what are some
of the things I might change and just
anything else you want to tell me
thank you that's it
[Applause]